et avec les usines et tout ça ça fait de
la pollution et la nature n'avait pas
conservé
c'est pas bien c'est pas bien parce que
quand on arrive on au lendemain il y en
a presque plus une nature du tout des
jeunes déjà préoccupés par la pollution
dans les années 70 à cette époque
plusieurs catastrophes écologiques ont
déjà eu lieu les pollutions
industrielles et la protection de la
nature deviennent alors des enjeux
écologiques la sensibilisation des
jeunes au respect de l'environnement est
donc une priorité en 1965
cette professeure introduisait cette
notion auprès de ses élèves je pense que
si on veut sauver quelque chose pour
commencer par les élèves pour commencer
par leur apprendre à respecter respecter
l'environnement mais surtout agir pour
la protection de la nature en 1970 des
collégiens de noirmoutier organisé une
opération alerte à la pollution sur le
riz armés de sacs
il aidait les cantonniers au ramassage
des déchets une initiative locale saluée
par le sous-préfet des sables-d'olonne
eh bien vous avez montré que vous pouvez
remuait beaucoup de monde un an plus
tard en 1971
robert poujade fraîchement nommé au
premier ministère de l'environnement
appelait tous les jeunes français à
participer à la protection de la planète
une campagne nationale de
sensibilisation été lancé dans toutes
les écoles françaises
si l'environnement était seulement la
sphère du gouvernement et des ministres
nous ne pourrions pas réussir d'affaires
pour l'environnement il faut que ce soit
tous les français depuis les plus petits
jusqu'aux plus grands action pour
l'environnement et certains enfants
avaient déjà des idées visionnaires pour
préserver la terre comment est ce qu'on
peut faire pour lutter contre la
pollution
qu'est-ce qui a des idées en scène de
soi et cliquer oui le plus possible de
choses et les griffes des départs en
classe mais aussi des expositions et des
concours permettent aux enfants de faire
part de leurs idées pour sauvegarder la
planète
en 1978 le biologiste alain bombard
s'étonnait de leur maturité dans ce
domaine on est vraiment frappé de voir
non seulement avec la table quelle
passion il se préoccupe de savoir ce que
sera leur monde de demain est faux culs
beaucoup de l'état lequel on leur laisse
le monde
ce sont eux qui rendent leurs parents
conscients devenu adulte ces jeunes des
années 70 sont aujourd'hui toujours
autant préoccupés par les questions
environnementales
selon un sondage ifop 86% les français
entre 50 et 64 ans sont inquiets du
réchauffement climatique
[Musique]